now what are your rates when the weather
strikes or even both of them throw your
travel plans into disarray well the
independence travel editor Simon Calder
is here to provide all the information
you need Simon lovely to see you before
we do I wonder if I might just get your
view on what is happening in that
industrial dispute between the DFT and
the rmt you are listening to Mick
Lynch's Mick Lynch's interview there and
you know his point is that the the
government is seeking these strikes that
it is acting in a manner which actively
encourages them well I think talking to
the traveling public and I've been round
at some of the main London stations this
morning and there are trains running
um that uh well we've got this Unholy
Trinity of Christmas weather and Strikes
and we're now I think moving into the
plague on both your houses uh stage of
the Public's view on this but you
absolutely summed it up perfectly when
you said to well Mike Mark Harper
earlier did you intervene and he uh
declined to answer and uh yes it is
entirely about two Sundays ago and I was
being briefed by various policies
involved in this and simply couldn't
believe it when they lobbed in something
which they knew would be um completely
toxic so it is going to carry on I'm
afraid the next day that we can look
forward to completely normal we hope
subjects of the weather train services
will I make it be um January the 9th so
four weeks of uh disruption and the
public is saying to me at least um you
know life is hard enough without having
to stagger through these strikes as well
as everything else unfortunately we're
going to talk about strikes again but
but a separate set of them the PCS Union
industrial action by the UK border force
staff I mean what is happening there and
how is that going to have an impact okay
so on the 23rd of December 1 000 members
of the PCS Union working for the UK
border force will walk out at six
airports Heathrow Gatwick Manchester
those are the biggest three in the UK
also Birmingham Cardiff and Glasgow this
is in a dispute about paper pensions and
job security Now the these are the very
good men and women who check the
passports as you go in as you know you
don't have go through UK border force on
your way out it will be checked by
airport staff but not officially and
they will not be working from the 23rd
to the 26th then there's a day of
respite and then the last four days of
the year
um and they say that this will cause
significant disruption obviously are the
airlines canceling flights already right
okay so it all depends who you talk to
right
um the UK border Force I understand is
modeling what happens I mean if you just
take Heathrow Airport I counted 50
wide-bodied flights from
InterContinental
destinations arriving before seven
o'clock this morning okay that
represents
um somewhere around 12 000 people many
of whom won't have UK or EU or North
American passports and will need to be
properly processed rather than going
through the e-gates and yes you can
bring in the military and they can help
but ultimately you are going to have
longer Jews as normal you can envisage
your situation where the planes actually
the pilots are told keep everybody on
board because we cannot get room and
that means that the departing plane
doesn't go so you get all kinds of cues
building up in Departures all the gates
fill up so you can't bring planes in you
get diversions and cancellations
preemptively it might be that we get
some cancellations Manchester Airport
says we certainly will Gatwick says we
won't and heathrow's boss yesterday John
Holland K said we think there might be a
little bit of impact on arriving
passengers but we're going to get
everybody away to their destinations is
that something that you can then claim
for if you haven't had had a delay on a
single flight that you're getting off
and you're coming through the departure
but more than that I mean if you are
connecting well yeah if you're doing any
kind of connecting flight then you
should just be traveling on one ticket
so if you were for instance go going
through Gatwick and you came in on one
low-cost Airline and transferred to
another low-cost Airlines flight that's
not a through ticket you're on your own
you might be able to get a bit of
insurance but actually if you've got a
through ticket then it is absolutely the
airline's responsibility and if they do
start canceling planes in advance then
you just they've got to book you on the
first plane which is going to get you to
your destination on the right day even
if that means they have to buy you a
ticket on another airline the trouble is
of course this time of year planes are
flying full there aren't that many empty
seats that's true what about the railway
Network I mean clearly I think people
have been you know forewarned about the
extent of the strikes that are going to
take place if they don't sort themselves
out but for people who have bought
tickets or people who buy on the game
and what what for them look there are
thousands of trains running around the
UK today and if for instance between
Edinburgh and London nine trains each
way and sure they're shutting down early
around half past six in the evening but
you can just walk up and buy a ticket
just you normally would if you've got an
advanced ticket then you get a whole
menu of options you can get a cash
refund you can get a voucher don't know
why you would want to do that or you can
travel in the days before the strike
while it's now on or in the days
afterwards so huge amounts of
flexibility and actually
um collapsing ticket revenue of course
for the government which ultimately is
is directing pretty much all the
operations in the railways these days
really really briefly because we are out
of time but giving your contacts with
the rmt and indeed at DFT I do wonder if
you see a way through this do you think
that there is going to be a solution I'm
afraid we're going to have to sit
through this all the way to the first
week of January and you could tell from
your interview with Mick Lynch he
desperately wants a settlement he's his
members don't want to lose any more
money they want to find a way out it's a
now I think down to the government yeah
Simon called it lovely to see you thanks
for joining us